filmmakers have a lot of tricks up their
sleeves but the way James Cameron was
able to make the Titanic set look bigger
is probably the most hilarious thing
we've ever heard leave it to the guy who
directed three of the top five highest
grossing films of all time to come up
with such a goofy trick but before we
get to the funny there's the budget of
course money is going to make all the
difference and the budget for Titanic
cost a bit more than pocket change at a
whopping 200 million in the late '90s
making it the most expensive film of its
time a small chunk of that budget
initially just 10% was allocated for the
set but Cameron being the perfectionist
he is wanted everything to be spot on so
the set costs doubled to nearly 40
million but here's the fun part to make
the set look as colossal as the real
Titanic Cameron played a little casting
trick he only hired extras shorter than
5'8 to create the illusion of a massive
ship